everything's bigger in Texas including
their gay porn consumption the Bible
about leads the United States and
consumption of gay porn according to the
recent data for pornhub.com according to
the websites findings Mississippi leads
the country in gay porn viewership at
5.6 percent not to be outdone Louisiana
and Georgia are close behind at five
point four percent on average every
state in the south watches gay porn at a
higher percent than the average of
states where gay marriage is legal so we
just did a segment which will link to
down below about these kids in high
school that were forming an anti-gay
Club Rick you made the point that all of
this stuff is just based in homophobia
it's basically it's making the sellers
purely business model mechanical dynamic
of making future customers for the
business and the gays don't reproduce at
a rate satisfactory to that business
model and so they manufacture hatred for
something that impedes their business
and that's all this is they're just
worker ants to them you know and while
they're doing it they're consuming gay
porn apparently they're consuming gay
porn in the states where you're not
supposed to be gay at all yeah that
means a lot of hidden away stuff you
know a lot of people not able to quit
each other most of this probably
reflects a bit of a you know it which
you can identify with they've some sort
of personal tragedy happening at that
moment cuz this is probably not it might
be some Crusaders against gays who
secretly go home at night but more
likely it's because there are men and
this is all study of men they left out
lesbians because a lot of the lesbian
porn is probably watched by men um but
actually right that were joking but it's
a good point yeah I was enjoy guys up on
the UH but um yeah they California's a
like eighty seven percent after Rick
Overton but you got early kids in the
states they mentioned Mississippi
Georgia Louisiana other states in the
South not even kids grown men dangerous
when it's kids uh but grown men who are
afraid to be who they are and have no
outlet maybe don't date maybe don't even
or
able to have intimate relationships with
other men and so porn is pornography is
literally going to be their outlet for
that so I mean I see those stats and
that just there's a sadness in that I
think all yeah so it's really it's a
double-edged sword it's the people that
are forcing these laws and the people
that then can't act in communities where
you don't feel like you can say you know
what it turns out okay right and yeah
I'd love a hug but you're not gonna get
a hug you're gonna get a uh you're gonna
get shot
yeah is there anything that surprises
you about this then this it's pretty
straightforward right it's strangely
reassuring that there's an undercurrent
of or whatever humanity is trying to
become still going on it just looks like
these different things right now but it
seems like uh in 25 years Texas could be
an entirely different colored place yeah
or sooner it's happening right breaking
apart the oh this means it's
disintegrating the old model like
evolution does yeah so where does this
put the the gay marriage thing for you
because I'm sort of okay with the way
that it's just happening state-by-state
if that's the way it's gonna happen and
that's the way it's gonna happen for
weed as opposed to the the federal
government coming in and just making out
its it didn't take that long actually if
you look at his last we mean out total
government nice tact I think and I I
mean I think spring portal will settle
it you know I you know it yes it in a
general in a general sense having it
happen state-by-state is okay but there
are gay people living in that state and
who that don't have it that should be
able to get married and sure they
shouldn't have to leave Georgia and move
to Maryland just because they you know
love a guy alright I don't know that I
can add anything else in that well said
guys what do you think gays porn
marriage there's a lot there let us know
your thoughts in the comments right now